"Liftoff on Apollo 11..."
"Tranquility base, the eagle has landed."
50 years ago, Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
became the first humans to ever land on the moon.
One small step for man, one giant leap for mankind,
that whole thing.
Astronauts also brought back
the first samples of the moon.
They brought back rocks and soil
from the lunar surface.
"These boxes include
the samples of various types of rock,
the ground mass of the soil, the sand and silt..."
Having Apollo samples here on the ground
where we can study them
changed entire field of planetary science.
It's revealed stuff, not only about the moon,
but about how other planetary surfaces
change and evolve.
And we continue to study them today.
They're still revealing secrets about the moon itself
and the rest of the solar system.
NASA keeps most of those samples
at the NASA Johnson Space Center in Houston
in a secure, pristine clean room...
that I got to go visit.
So I showed up at the lab, and I met Charisse Krysher.
What I do is I prepare Apollo moon rock samples
for our scientists out in the community
so that they can do research.
They keep all the rocks in a cleanroom
and for the lucky people who get to go in there
the price of admission is putting on this crazy suit
that's supposed to keep all of your human stuff
from getting anywhere near the rocks.
[music]
The last step was an air shower.
Please watch your step.
It actually felt more like a light breeze.
[Elevator music]
There's moon rocks out there.
There are a bunch of clean rooms at NASA Johnson,
but this one is called the Lunar Pristine Samples Lab.
That's because the moon rocks stored here
have not been exposed to Earth air at all
since they arrived back on Earth in the 60s and 70s.
Here you have a lot of water in the air,
and you have a lot of oxygen in the air.
And as soon as a rock is exposed to the Earth's surface,
it gets attacked by those two things,
and the minerals inside those rocks
start to change immediately.
The pristine rocks are kept in these special cabinets
that are filled with pure nitrogen instead of earth air.
And they have a higher pressure on the inside
than the outside.
So if air ever escapes,
it comes out and away from the rocks
instead of things going in
to potentially contaminate the rocks.
It feels like it's hugging my arms really tight in there.
That's the pressure? Alright. Cool.
[ding]
Only three materials can come into
contact with these rocks.
They're aluminum, Teflon and stainless steel.
So first you have your gloves in your bunny suit,
then you have the gloves that let
you reach into the cabinet,
and if you want to pick up a sample directly,
you have to put on Teflon gloves on top of that.
So what the lunar sample processors do in this room
is they prepare rocks to send out to researchers
who can then study them.
To do that, they have to break off little chips of the rocks
Sometimes they use buzz saws.
Sometimes they use a hammer and a chisel.
Sometimes they just scoop up some soil and weigh it.
And then they can package it up
and send it off into the world.
I used to work in a lab
where we worked with pictures of Mars
from the Mars rovers Spirit and Opportunity.
My job was to process pictures of dirt
as they were sent back to Earth.
And all I wanted was to scoop up some of that Mars dirt
and just let it run through my fingers.
I figured this was the closest I could get
to actually touching some extraterrestrial space dirt.
Am I allowed to reach in and hold the thing or no?
[Sigh] Um I'm afraid not.
Can we do it?
Uh we cannot.
Unfortunately, no one is allowed to touch
the moon rocks in the pristine lab.
That's the whole point of the pristine lab.
But I did get to hold a sample
that was encased in this acrylic trophy,
which was pretty darn good.
This is a moon rock... in my hand!
When the processors are ready
to send a sample out to a researcher,
they pack them up really carefully,
and then they just ship them out
through the regular mail.
They don't label it 'this is a moon rock' or anything.
They don't label them fragile.
And they don't even insure them
because what would you insure it for?
They're priceless.
When samples come back,
researchers mail them back.
And they're no longer pristine
because they've been outside
of those nitrogen cabinets.
Those rocks are mostly available
to use again in other studies.
The processors keep very careful track
of everything that has ever happened to them.
So that researchers know whether previous experiments
can affect their current experiments.
At least a little bit of every single sample
has been analyzed.
We have roughly about 80% of our collection
is still considered pristine.
Um we have about...
about 5% is out display, on display.
Another 5% is out to our scientists around the world.
And another 15% of each sample
is in a remote storage facility at another NASA center
just in case something happened to this facility
and we lost the samples in this facility.
One of the things these rocks have told us
is that the moon probably formed in a giant impact
where the early Earth, when it was still hot molten
four and a half billion years ago,
collided with another protoplanet.
That might have been about the size of Mars.
The debris from that collision splashed out into space
and congealed to form the moon.
"...I'm picking up several pieces
of really vesicular rock our here now."
At the end of Apollo 11,
when Neil Armstrong was finishing up
the first moonwalk ever,
he was packing up the rocks into this sample box
that they were going to bring back to Earth.
And he saw that there was some space left in it,
and he didn't want the big rocks to jostle around,
so he threw in some scoops of soil
to kind of cushion them.
Best idea that he could have had
because they ended up bringing back so much sample
that there were a lot of outlying studies
that could be done
that wouldn't have gotten samples otherwise.
The soils from Apollo 11 contained
these little white rocks called anorthosites.
These are not very dense.
These are really light rocks.
And scientists thought that maybe
they had floated to the surface
of an ancient lunar magma ocean,
and formed a crust
that used to cover most of the moon.
Over the years, instruments get better,
new instrumentation is invented,
new techniques come about.
There are questions we can answer now
that scientists didn't even know to ask in the 70s.
So keeping these samples pristine
will help scientists for the next 50 years
answer questions that we haven't even thought of today.
[music]